okay let's talk about this look I mean
how are you feeling in it but also how
long did it take I feel like a million
dollars I resemble the dollar green and
um I think it took like upwards of maybe
five to six hours a long time but so
worth it I have a lot of patience that's
what everyone said today also how do you
have like no green on you I'm so back
literally I do my hands a little bit
just this one yeah
they did a great job yeah you know they
took a lot of time put it yeah
you did a great job
oh my gosh well you know I feel like you
guys are just crushing it I mean you are
crushing it week after week how does it
feel to be on the top of the leaderboard
again
it feels so good I just feel like it's
huge validation for how hard we work
during the week and to be on the top
with you know Charlie and Wayne like
their top performers each in their own
craft so I don't know I feel like it's
an honor
um and how much fun was this for you I
mean do we see like a Marvel future like
film appearance maybe
show Marvel what you oh
I like that I feel like what okay we
don't call the Hitman we're gonna call
the hip man to come
seduce your significant other yes
I love it I think that's great
um you know is there a particular dance
style that you are really looking
forward to or maybe one that you're a
little bit nervous about heading into
the coming weeks
um not necessarily I feel like maybe I
don't know enough yet to have an opinion
is there one that you really want to see
her do
I'm excited for uh Argentine Tango I'm
excited for
the foxtrot I'm excited for contemporary
you know I'm excited for any dance that
that we do together and hopefully we get
to do a lot of them
um you know as someone who's been on the
show for a number of Seasons what do you
think it's Disney plus tonight so I have
to ask what is this Disney plus move
been like what do you think about it I
think it's been incredible for the show
um
for the people that are part of the show
I feel
loved and celebrated you know I think
Dancing with the Stars has earned its
right to be you know up there and the
talent that make up the success of the
show uh deserves to be celebrated and
this this year with Disney plus I feel
celebrated I feel as a show and as a a
talent on the show I see the Billboards
I see the you know there's been a lot of
effort and you can feel it and you can
feel it every day so I'm very proud with
the movement I'm proud to be a part of
it